jane toma de la nevera un gran cubo de
mantequilla cuyo lado mide 5 luego corta
un pequeño cubo cuyo lado mide dos de
una de las esquinas del cubo escribe una
expresión numérica que describe el
volumen de mantequilla que quedó
recuerda que el volumen de un cubo está
calculado a través de sus lados en este
caso tenemos cinco lo que implica que
para que nosotros calculamos el volumen
de este primer cubo tendríamos 5 por 5
por 5 o 5 al cubo vamos a reescribir lo
como 5 al cubo
si nosotros tenemos este gran cubo que
mide 5 de lado y le cortamos un pequeño
cubo que mide 2 de lado lo que haremos
es restarle porque estamos buscando la
mantequilla que quedó restaremos el
volumen de este segundo cubo que
habíamos quedado que el volumen de un
cubo se calcula como lado por lado por
lado en este caso estoy utilizando el 2
dado que es la medida que tiene cada
lado de este cubo chico sin embargo
también podemos reescribirlo con motors
al cubo y de esta manera tendríamos una
expresión numérica que nos describe el
volumen de mantequilla que nos queda
vamos a comprobar nuestra respuesta
y es correcta